It was a pretty typical school day. Uh, 800 students at the high school
where I worked as a guidance
counselor. And I was about to go into a meeting with a
college representative who was going to meet with some juniors and seniors and try to recruit them
to his college.
college. And the guidance secretary pulled me aside and she whispered
into my ear, "Paul,
there's a student in the front office. He's got five hostages
and he has a gun." "Sally,
who are the hostages?" Turns out it's the two assistant principals and three secretaries. Our principal
was out of the building at the time.
"Who's the student?" "It's Andy."
My heart sinks cause I talk with Andy every day.
He's actually a teddy bear and. It's not adding up in my book. I don't
understand this.
This is four and a half years before Columbine.
There's no protocol in place.
All we know how to do is get out if there's a fire.
And so I call the police.
police and the dispatcher immediately
gets me to, uh, an officer.
And he said, "Paul here's what you need to do, you need to get all the students and staff out of
the building.
But you can't pull the fire alarm.
You can't alert Andy to the fact that they're leaving the building because he might
start shooting. [pause]
Here's a good time for me to tell you that I'm on
crutches. [crowd laughs] Recovering from major knee surgery and
I can't put weight on my knee. And I'm thinking how are we going to get
800 students out of here. But a buddy of mine, Dave,
Dave, walks into the guidance office.
And I let him know what we've got to do. There's two two big wings. And I sent him to one wing,
the technology wing and I go to the classroom
wing. I'm hobbling there and on the
way I, I stop in the the conference room. And I say to the college representative.
"We've got a guy with a gun in the office. You might
want to get out of here.
But use a side door or you can stay if you want. But I would get out of
of here." And he leaves.
And I hobbled down to the classroom wing.
And I go from classroom to classroom
classroom. And I just directly look
at the teacher.
And I say. You need to listen to me.
You need to listen and do exactly what I say. You can't
ask any questions.
You need to leave now. You need to
leave as quietly as you can.
And don't take anything with you.
And every teacher
knew that this was serious but I remember specifically, Patty,
these beautiful brown eyes just getting bigger and
bigger as they connected with mine.
And she knew something was
terribly wrong.
And she looked at her students and she said "OK,
let's do exactly what. Mr Knowles said.
Every classroom left.
Every student left. I think one of my colleagues did the second floor
because I don't remember getting up
there. But I think within two to three minutes we had that classroom, that wing
cleared.
You could hear a pin drop when everyone was leaving, that's how quiet everyone
was. The last teachers leaving the classroom wing and I decide
I'm just going to stay put because I knew I was the only one that was in touch with the police.
And then all of a sudden, Andy comes around the corner.
He's got two assistant principals with him and he's about fifteen feet
away. And he points the rifle at me.
I'm not much of a. I've never hunted.
hunted. But it's a 30 ought 6 with a
scope. And he's got bullets wrapped around his waist
and they're 2 to 3 inches long
and I was. I got scared.
But I stayed calm. Andy's about 6' 2''
maybe 6'1''.
He's bigger than me, and without the gun I wouldn't want to take him on- I'm certainly not going to take
him on with the gun. And he said Mr Knowles I want you to get all the students
in front of the building
and I'm in a little bit of a quandry
here because as a counselor, I like want to save Andy. This guy who I talk with
every day. Some days he calls me Paul/
We're kind of friends. But then we just cleared this building of
800 students. What's my priority here? Do I do what he wants
so that everyone stay safe?
I don't know where the answer came from.
But I just said to Andy. I'm sorry, Andy.
I can't do that.
And I turn my back to him.
And I start to leave. Honestly thinking he might fire
his gun at me. Being a little ticked off that I didn't listen to him.
He didn't. And as I'm leaving the building I could
tell he was behind me and he was going to follow out the building. And when I get out of the
the building
I realize oh my god. We have just sent
all these students into a cage.
Our evacuation area for fire drill is the softball field.
So now all these students are enclosed in this fenced-in area.
And then we got a student coming out of the building with a rifle.
rifle. I feel if I start yelling,
he'll come out quicker.
quicker. Remembering the police officer said, "Do this quietly."
So I take my crutches. And I just start waving frantically at the top of this hill looking down
on everyone and I'm hoping they understand.
Get! Leave! Run! He's coming out! Go!
Go! But they're not moving. They don't know what the waving of the crutches is about.
And Andy's a couple steps away from coming outdoors so I go around the corner to be out of
his sight so I could keep waving.
But no one's moving and then I hear the gunshot
and I see people running.
And I just - I thought maybe
the shot was coming my way again but clearly after a couple seconds you know it didn't come your way
and for me these I felt like I needed to get back in the building.
So I take a few minutes to get around to the front side and I don't know what happened I don't know where the shot went
I decide to go back to the guidance office
and I called the police again.
This is Paul. What you want me to do? How can I help?
And they said, we don't know where Andy is, but he's back in the building.
Can you find him? Can you get him to pick up the phone? We need to talk to him. We want to negotiate with them.
I'm not sure how to do that. So I decide I'm just going to stay put and I just
from the guidance office I just keep calling the- the main office.
Pick up. Pick up, come on someone pick up, pick up.
I just kept trying, I kept trying.
Eventually the assistant principal John picked up.
Thank God. John, John you need to get Andy to pick up the phone the police
wanna talk to him.
Is Andy there and he said yeah Andy's here.
So Andy did pick up the phone.
He did get into a discussion with the police. So in
So in the meantime I call my link with the police department back and I say all right,
Andy's talking what he want me to do and they told me to get out of the building.
But at that point, I'm thinking I'm not sure I think this guidance office is pretty safe so I'm just going to
hang here for a few minutes and I actually go into my little office. And I crouch behind the
desk. And that's when it really hit me
because I have this 9 month old daughter back at my
house
and her mom. And I'm wondering...
"Am I going to get to be a father still." And
I just spent three minutes focused on my family. Missing them
them and feeling sad. Not scared. Just sad,
that this day was happening.
But after about three minutes of this I decided to leave the building
and went out the loading dock and as I go up the loading dock, out from behind the dumpster,
dumpster, state trooper. Point's his gun at me.
Thank God he had good training cause he didn't fire. And he ran up to me and he goes where's Andy? And
how do I get there so I gave him directions.
I got myself to safety still not really sure what happened. Well,
Well, Andy did surrender. He walked out the front of
building. I didn't see this, this is as told to me. And he lays
his gun down. And
lights a cigarette.
As it turns out his shot was a warning shot.
Later that day I went back to that softball field.
And it was one of the most surreal and profound images that I will always remember.
Because in that softball field
are backpacks, shoes, papers, musical instruments.
There's parts of the fence where it was literally run over by all the students and staff.
And what did have. What had happened
is that teachers in high heels were helped over
the fence. We had a student in a wheelchair and he was carried over
that fence. And while it looked like a U.F.O. had come along
and plucked everyone out of that field and taken them away,
what it really was
Is that all those students and staff, somehow
by helping each other
found their way to the safety of the community. To the safety
of the woods and the nearby homes and the nearby stores. So
So what that image represents to me, as eerie as it is, is the fact
the fact that on that day, even though we didn't really know what to do,
we actually trusted each other, we took care of each other
other and in my mind, It was 800 heroes that somehow
worked together
on a day where we, a lot of people, could have gotten hurt.
hurt. But instead, no one got hurt.
And I thank my 800 colleagues
on that day
that helped make it as positive as we could.
Thank you
[applause]
[cheering]